today's episode is brought to you by
gray block pizza gray block pizza it's
that pizzeria that makes you really
smile and if you've had it if you have
it in your mouth you just know you're
really gonna fall in love with yourself
great block pizza get that hitter what's
up you little drastic Rascals huh what's
going on with you you little November
timbers it's time to chop down all the
[ __ ] and fall into the end of the
year you got me the holidays are coming
you can hear Santa on the out there
listen outside your window what is that
what do you think it is huh you think
that's a couple homeless fighting over a
um a dural log nope when an umber of
flame logs like I heard in Cleveland
nope
listen outside you win to put your ear
up to the ground what is that a horse
hoof nope that's a deer it's time baby
the holidays are zoom and Taurus tore a
Taurus like a meteorite that's right
maybe like a meteorite like a meteor
wrong wouldn't it be crazy if they had a
meteor wrong and it's like uh it's like
oh hey I just thought uh I'm supposed to
be a meteor ride but uh you know I
messed up or he like doesn't do well on
his test or whatever but unlike his
space tests anyway speaking of space
let's get into with this man right here
welcome to this past weekend
a little bit of Stevie starlight
[Music]
[Applause]
set me free
just don't say goodbye love this enjoy
the destination TV star like come over
yes
- name
inside Smith
[Applause]
so don't as
Oh
we
why must we wait when we're alive
Stevie hits it on the hay he hits it on
the head right there and he puts the
hammer on the head dude he's that bull
in your skull right there he really it's
just that farm animal that runs right
into your brain with that fact that
skull bull he said hey why must be
weight when we're alive
happy November or bro vember whatever it
is I there's too many
it's like oh it's hoe member some girls
like oh well you know I'm doing sex with
everyone this time like what what are
you talking about mom you know
somebody's like oh yeah dude it's crow
vember you know I'm only on buying a
couple of buzzards you know I'm getting
I'm buying a crow from the pet shop you
ain't doing [ __ ] brah and they're like
yeah I'm doing it for like leprosy or
some kind of you know there's just too
many things now it's like oh it's um you
know it's uh it's um it's fro vember and
I'm gonna grow out my you know i'ma grow
up my fro or I'm gonna grow up my letter
you know if you're white you only can do
a fro around your pink around your
Weiner around your kind of thighs or
something or a lot of me and get that
rear but fro it at the baseline of each
butt cheek they'll have a strong real
mass of hair right there and you could
because some of them you'll see a man at
the gym or something I don't see a lot
of those men because I don't look at
them but every now and then you know my
phone will run out of power and so I'll
have to look at other stuff in the gym
and you'll see a man in there whose
backside is all wet and you have a lot
of it almost looks like his butt looks
like two closed eyes and the there's a
ton of hair right there at the bottom
looked like um you know like eyelashes
cuz I'll you know almost coming off with
like it like the closed eyes of you know
his
you know his butt cheeks each one look
like a closed eye of his butt cheeks and
you see they got a lot of hair right
there on a man sometimes but it's
interesting that that
yeah but yet they just got too many too
many different things it's Movember you
can't shave your buddy you can't do this
you got a mustache you know there's just
too many of them I can't name them right
now for some reason but but there's just
too many different and it's always for
something you know it's like oh we're um
you know we're not going to open our
eyes it's like it's dark vember you know
and for two weeks we're not gonna open
our eyes and we're raising money for you
know for blind people or something
you're like I'm not doing all of that
[ __ ] you know I gotta ride my bike to
work on my doing it with my eyes closed
so you can eat a can of can of
straight-up streetside ass meat if
you're thinking about that but what's
happening yeah it's November we're
getting into it we're getting into it
it's never too late to come over it's
never too late a real beauty about life
you get these you know they you just get
to eat the next day comes running you
get that fresh opportunity you know it's
like the powers that be the existence
you know it's like life just every day
opens up that fresh can of hot fish
right there for you say here you go
again
speaking of fish I was um I did
Halloween I went to a get-together and I
had a you know I ended up going with
like a newsie costume I did it last year
like a newspaper boy do you think about
newspaper boys like it used to be when I
was young somebody had a paper route
you'd see some little kid you know
somebody this guy you know fat Samuel
somebody little Daniel out there smoking
a cigarette and uh and and you'd get a
paper route and somebody would ride
their bike in the morning and throw
papers out and my mother used to do a
mother used to deliver uh newspapers and
magazines and still does some but this
was you know she was real regular at it
and but they'd have children would do it
and it was even before my time where you
would hear a lot of children would get
out and do a paper route think about
that you're 11 years old it's 5:30 in
the morning you out there slinging the
sports section at somebody nowadays you
can't get one of these little [ __ ]
to frickin make you know to make his own
to make a salad for himself
you could lock a kid in a cage with a
whole thing of salad mix with some with
a bag of spring mix and uh you know in a
hat full of um peppercorns and whatever
be black olives and he would [ __ ] it up
I mean these kids I don't know I don't
even know some of them are more like
animals more you know I bet they would
test if you tested them they would test
more as animals some of them some of the
youth but anyway speaking of fish so I'm
out there I go to the traffic was so bad
on Sunset Boulevard that I'm leaving I'm
leaving I stopped by the Comedy Store
that's and I'm leaving and traffic was
so bad it was just going nowhere and you
know just groups of people walking by
costumes so two of my buddies are on a
street corner about a viper room and so
I pull off there on Sunset I park and we
walked down to Santa Monica Boulevard
and that's where it's real I mean it
gets a
real homoerotic down there and it's
really a it's kind of like the
Mississippi River for like gay men but
it's not a river it's just a street and
so they got you know everybody's just
popping and locking and and they have
but during Halloween it's a big festival
it's a big like everybody's all types of
people out there costumes everybody and
it's and everybody's welcome and stuff
it's just it's um you know it's kind of
like it's kind of uh it's more it's more
like they block off the street block
party so they blocked the street off and
then so I'm walking with two of my
buddies we're gonna go maybe walk into a
bar they're meeting some ladies over at
a spot dude we get probably half a block
down the boulevard and they got a young
fella over there dressed as um and this
guy might have been kind of like maybe
Filipino or maybe light Mexican or he
could have been actually you know we had
a group of people grown by us the
Swanson's and they lived by like a real
smoky area and so they weren't they were
white but they was real smoked so if you
didn't think they were and sometime
people would you know lob a little lob a
couple couple little slurs at him you
know and they'd it be like oh no it's
just smoke you know we got just some
smoke on us but but this boy had dressed
up like Arial you know from not like the
aerial nation or whatever but it like
the aerial that water gingerbreading I'm
talking about aerial from Little
Mermaid's
so this guy it was a mermaid this little
guy and he was kind of he looked more
like a trout to me I think he was a
little bit more he was kind of
rubenesque but his buddies I guess some
friends have been carrying them and they
got pissed at him
and set him down so this too is just
screaming he's just yelling for somebody
named Jesse to come back and pick him up
and that was just one of the most
traumatic things I've ever seen and I'm
that catch-and-release guy if any season
you know I don't know how many mermaids
you're allowed to keep but I said damn
they got to throw this boy back man
cuz they just laid this young buck right
out there and this did was just
floundering and you could tell and he
was at that point he was kind of he
would reach him men's legs when they
walk by like he was just looking for any
man and just put him in his little in
his boat and he just you know he was
just like finding hemo like he was just
just looking for any he that that would
be around but that was probably the most
craziest thing really that I saw was
just a man that was abandoned that had
dressed up like um like aerialists from
the dam whatever little mermaids but
that's it that's what happened what else
did I do not do anything real crazy um I
watched the fights
I watched the fights man and I thought
dude did I watch the till Gastelum fight
I couldn't believe that they didn't
really father was like what's going on
it's almost like they timed a treaty or
something before the fight and didn't
tell anybody and Darren till if you look
at him he looks like the mask from
scream if you noticed that when you see
him just facially
he's starting to really look like the
scream mask he looks like a piece of
like Vincent van Gogh art if you look at
him but you know I respect a guy I think
it's really hard to probably go to
another country and live there I don't
know I think Darren's he'll lives here
and fight or just to go to another
country and fight like just to just that
that just seems real intense to me but I
was hoping the gasolin would win that
one out just didn't I didn't understand
why they didn't get into it
what else man we got a lot of other
stuff I'm gonna actually we'll have Nick
come in because he likes to talk about
the fights and then I'll get into some
other things well and we'll go over a
little bit of news and then I'll get
into some into some questions but it's
you know what this is this is a special
time of year when we have you know when
it is you can kind of recalibrate I
think November or bro vember or whatever
it is a time for you to you know finally
admit your neighbor that you guys are
family you guys are brothers or to hug a
brother you know find a black friend and
hug it hug him tell him you love him
brush bro member you know or or Grove
ember if you're 11 years old do this
Grove ember and you probably you might
be you you could be you could maybe grow
an inch if you try real hard this month
November November is just that month
that it's just like come on come on in I
don't doesn't matter what's been
happening come on in because we got the
holidays and everybody's welcome and
that's a beautiful thing about November
I'll tell you this the the shows almost
sold out they're in Lafayette Louisiana
and that isn't gonna be in AH a December
26th at the Heyman Center and that
beautiful things almost sold out with
proceeds to benefit Dustin Poirier
Foundation and Dustin's gonna come out
it's gonna be it's gonna be a fun time
and then what else Oh we'll get the
shows coming up you know in um
Manchester they still have tickets
available from Manchester in January in
the UK and also for Sweden and Stockholm
and Norway Oslo and Stockholm I think
everything else on the European Tour's
uh is sold out
December 10th I'll be in Los Angeles at
the at the at The Wiltern downtown and
those tickets are all available on one
at theof on comm slash
tor and some new dates we do have some
new dates they're not I'll have to put
them on social media this week they got
that magic place Toronto is finally
going to be on and we're gonna get the
Maryland and sayers ville and then we're
hoping to shoot a comedy special we
don't have a buyer for it yet people are
always saying when you're gonna do a
special yeah I don't know you know I
mean I'm always gonna be returning new
material I mean the dark art store is
different half of it's different now
than when it started so it's always
going to be the ball is always going to
be rolling and I think well you know
we'll get some offers it's just a matter
of you know we're you know is it as
something that's fair and then where do
you put it if not then you just you you
get some of the clips and you get it and
you do it on YouTube or put it I don't
know but you know we figure it out but I
think we'll get some options for a
special because people are always asking
me it's not a it's not up to me you know
it's not up to me but nothing's ever
really come easy for me in this business
and and I don't intend I'd almost be
silly if I expected it to so but uh what
else man what else is cracking my hair
is coming in good you know I got them
they call me they call me buster
plugless Brooke cuz I got those hairs a
baby that damn second line that infantry
I got them reinforcements up top and
some of them they're real little you can
almost see him just kind of you can
almost touch them a little there's so
little man they just you almost don't
want to have somebody see you touching
them because they're just so damn young
you know it just seems like you just
like you shouldn't be doing it
let's do an ad man we got to do it cuz
the holiday rush is coming and if you
stealth if you
all stuff online you better get ready
with shipstation
and that's true think think about if you
want somebody to get something you can't
email uh you know a shirt to somebody
you can't email a box of socks or a
fresh thing a ravioli fresh made ravioli
you can't email it you can email a box
of cinnamon box of you know rock
cinnamon before they chisel it down and
powder it out but shipstation can help
with more people buying online than ever
before you have to be able to ship
orders out quickly efficiently and
affordably dude in the old days you
could take something to throw it as far
as you could and somebody would they get
it you know especially if they were
downhill from you but times have changed
luckily ship station can help with just
a few clicks you'll be managing orders
printing labels and getting those
products out the door and delivered in
time for the holidays ship station if
you like we'll send a lot of our
merchandise via ship station if you want
to get that new Rat King hit or you want
to get that um we get that get that hit
or white tee you know we get that little
we get that cartoon gang gang hit or
coming out and ship station we'll do it
no matter where you're selling through
Amazon Etsy or your own website ship
station brings all your orders into one
simple interface make it easy you can
even do it from your cell phone so take
the hassle out of holiday shopping let's
ship station handle it all with ease
just use my offer code theo th EO to get
a 60 day free trial that's two months
free of no hassle stress-free holiday
shopping
just visit ship station dot-com click on
the microphone at the top of the page
and type in Theo
that's ship station comm inter offer
code th EO make ship happen and also you
know if winter coming this is a time
when a man will I want to say it [ __ ]
something
in just that time you might walk past
and see your husband [ __ ] something
you know a shirt or pile of stack of
shirts or a thing of wet leaves or
something you know I never trusted a man
who would [ __ ] thing in dry leaves
that's always that's that's messed up
but if you see somebody just slip slide
anyway thing a wet leaves broth bought a
sidewalk or something
PG Burra praise God but if you love sex
or if you even like it then you'll like
blue chew finally a little snackable
that can get you dick really artsy blue
chew off errs many performance
enhancement for the bedroom so it used
to be in when I was growing up you had
to wear a cape or something you had to
jump off the top rope or something and
land on a mat now times have changed at
blue to calm you can get the first
chewable but the same active ingredients
as Viagra and Cialis chewables that work
faster than pills you see your buddy
across he's at the nightclub and he's
shoving a uh one of them viagra's and it
was a you know into that bang hole into
his B hole not you buddy you got blue
chew it only takes a few minutes go to
blue to calm an affiliated physician
affiliated physician that sounds mildly
shady but an affiliated physician what
is that's assumed that could be somebody
works at the horse track will get you
prescribed online quickly doesn't matter
the chewables from blue chew gum or
prescribed online by a doctor and made
in the USA they give you confidence in
bed every time look you're talking to a
guy for years and still and still will
show up to a [ __ ] party with that with a
soft boner that's how you know but
that's who I am bra you know I'm saying
they call me [ __ ] soft dick
McGillicuddy bra so and people say oh
that's not very effective but you you
know you give them a soft Wiener enough
bra
almost you know it's almost the same
blue to give you confidence in bed you
and your partner will love it here's a
great deal visit blue to calm get your
first order free when you use promo code
Theo that's right just pay $5 shipping
that's blue chook aam and use promo code
Theo
you know when I left the other night
that my buddies they wanted to go to the
bar or something to do they were meeting
some chicks and it just seemed like some
real thoughts out there and I said I'm
out of here bro
somebody abandoned this little mermaid
over here and they had the craziest
costumes I mean some of it wasn't even
we know one guy was just crying they had
a girl she had um she looked her thing
was Bernie Sanders but it was she had
lit the back of her the back of her suit
was on fire and that [ __ ] gets me man
why are you gonna burn yourself for a
pun that's a big ain't burning myself
you know if I was gonna be Bernadette
Wilson or somebody or whoever did the
American flag I wouldn't [ __ ] light
myself on fire so people could
understand it or whatever I don't know I
don't know do I ever know
let's get Nick in here we got some calls
and and we're gonna talk to him a little
bit about the fights and a little bit
about some news and just to change the
vibe up a little we'll just change it up
today and and it's that time of year to
to be inclusive and just include people
in what's going on you know if you if
you usually just go do something by
yourself
have somebody meet you you know recently
I haven't wanted to do that much stuff
sometimes and so instead I'll have
somebody meet me there Oh meet me that
way I have to go do it
oh then meet me at the gym that way I
have to be there just makes it a little
bit more accountable for myself and
and because I'm that guy a lot of times
I won't do something for me but if
somebody else if if somebody else is
included you know I'll do something for
somebody else so I'll meet them there
and and then it benefits me too because
it gets me going all right let's get
Nick in here what's up Nick
what's going on not much man did you
watch the fights you know I did I know
you did huh
trick question kind of I guess or what
what is it's not a trick question if I
know you know it that's a rhetorical
would you think man what do you think
first of that a Gastelum till fight it
was pretty boring I thought to be honest
I thought yeah I don't know I thought
they'd both be more aggressive but
Darren Till was saying some things after
the fight like he was like not in a
great headspace and like was thinking
about trying to make excuses to get out
of the fight so like that's why he was
like kind of tentative but he said he
kind of like settled in the whole time
and he made good points like gasps ylim
didn't touch him even though he wasn't
super aggressive like he dominated that
fight even though it wasn't the most
exciting yeah I thought it was just
interesting like I don't know enough
about fighting to know like is there
times where the guys where it's just a
bad matchup and they don't like their
styles they just never find ways to
really combat each other because those
guys I mean I've seen like square dance
and I've seen an aggressive square dance
and that was kind of harder yeah I think
that is what you said it just sometimes
people stylistic matchups keep them from
having because both those guys have had
just bangers of the fight like oh yeah
Kelvin Gastelum and Ezreal Adesanya had
maybe the fight of the year unbelievable
yeah that's when I was at that Poirier
fighting that thing was insane that
thing was insane watching them do that
so that I was expecting I guess I was
coming off the high of some of those
firework - expecting some of that out of
him and then Darren till you know he
needed a win I mean he said he's lost a
couple like two of his last four or
something I think so he really needed a
win
it just seemed I don't know yeah there
was even a couple times where it was
like did was - even gonna strike him
whenever he looked kind of like he could
have got one time I guess I'm fell
against the cage yeah yeah and he did
even swinging it has hit I think he just
like Nui was kind of ahead and
dominating and got kind of really
complacent I mean it's still a huge
statement for him because this is his
first fight at 185 and that at that
weight class and Gaston was like top 5
so like still a way to like open up in
that division but I agree it wasn't the
most exciting fight you know I wonder
why gasps I don't know if he kind of
waits for the fight to come to come to
him maybe he does a little bit he's so
short and has like doesn't have a very
long reach so like he really has to like
close the distance really fast and get
in there and maybe once he knew till had
his number and was just like keeping him
away from closing that distance he just
got he started to sit back and wait to I
thought he'd try to grapple more to be
honest but I don't know if he'll seemed
really strong and got up with a couple
times he did get taken down right away
yeah yeah Gasol is kind of like that
violent armadillo a little bit yeah you
know you got a we think they're not
gonna do much whenever you get close you
know armadillos can jump really high
I wasn't how to where people don't know
that and a lot of times they die they
get hit by cars because the car would go
over them but when the car gets close it
kind of reacts and jumps and then the
grille of the car hits it so that's how
a lot of um a lot of armadillos meet
their maker but what else what else what
else about the fight oh the the finale
the main event I thought it lived up to
the hype it was like the stoppage was a
little premature premature I would have
loved to see it did seem like Nate was
picking up in those last two rounds and
it would have been excited to see what
happens but they released the scorecards
and the judges had Jorge all three
judges had him winning all three of the
first round so the only chance Nate had
of winning was to stop them and I don't
know if that would have happened oh
watched he's so and now as the and the
fighters they know that they know that
like at a certain point they have to
know that's part of probably doing it
it's like the first couple of rounds
they give you off if I'm not gonna win
on the cards the only way I can win is a
knockout yeah yeah and usually good
corners will tell them be straight with
them like you're down you got to go for
it so it it definitely would have picked
up the pace and I think everybody wanted
to see the full fight yeah yeah
first I was fist I was furious I'm like
they let this do little nerd alert guy
in there some [ __ ] little statistic
juggler and this dude I mean it seemed
like they could have stitched him up
right there I guess but I guess it's
just at first I was upset and then I was
like once you kind of really saw his
face you're like oh man yeah that could
be some permanent damage I guess but it
I mean well you got to lose his faces
yeah he doesn't really have the best
yeah yeah he doesn't seem like he cares
if he has a face or not yeah his entire
face so far is scar tissue so what's
like a little bit more he's just gonna
have really bad scar again dude he had a
dang I mean he had like a couple vaginas
around his I mean this guy had really I
mean this guy giving him a real gender
identification issues around his eye you
know like I've gotten pinkeye from some
things but I've never had that bad a
pinkeye or to give to I keep built of a
giant on the top of his eye and built
one on the bottom that was dead looked
yeah cuz after if he gets hit again I
mean what maybe this is part of his face
this falls off I guess yeah I think that
might be nasty I was it was nasty
it was pretty graphic let's get into
some news man what happened in the news
this uh this weekend
um in some local news in the comedy
store parking lot
Bobby Lee hit Sam tripolis car after he
got out of his car while it was still in
Drive yes
well were you there for that I just got
just gotten there so I was actually in
my car when that happened thank God
because I was he's not safe when Bobby
and this isn't uh you know people will
try to say it's an Asian thing this is
that it's not first of all be a very
honest Bobby plays candy crush while he
drives his vehicle he got stopped by a
cop one time he told the cop it was a
Tesla it is not a Tesla that it was
self-driving he's not self-driving he
you will see him literally moving
forward and just playing candy crush and
it's very I think off-putting so I'm not
shocked that he hit Sam's car and here's
the crazy part Sam hadn't been in the
Comedy Store in a long time and he was
just kind of taking a little bit of
break he pulls in
[ __ ] Bobby dinged Umrah and it seems
to be kind of the go-to move for a lot
of Korean drivers hit somebody with
their car I got hit by a guy kim yong i
think was the guy's name dude and also
here's the thing his car had been hit
400 times it wasn't even a car it was a
hit it was just a hit it was like a
moving hit that and like a former life
had been a vehicle had no rearview
mirrors left on it it had in the inside
he taped like a house to me like a
mirror you would see at a barber like a
one you handheld he taped that to the
[ __ ] the inside middle and they they
found that it was my fault for him
hitting my car door ah I think I
remember that he got out of the car and
tried to embrace you yeah yeah he could
barely find me to him I come right here
dude that guy should not be driving that
God basically was just I don't even know
what you call that when you're just
moving forward but you're not really
like fully existent we're that guy was
really just like a ghost almost but what
else we got the Indian capital of Delhi
declared a pollution emergency for toxic
levels of smog the government was
handing out millions of masks and flight
operations at the airport have been
hampered because of low visibility I
don't know if you saw any the videos of
it but it looked like I don't know it
looked like The Grapes of Wrath like
dust storm just you couldn't see
anything and it that's just the air
there you go guys so you know what's a
layover because it is there that I mean
these guys dude India there's so many
people there's so many people even if
you don't have a family you have a
family there's like people living in
your house you'll open a cupboard and
there's a family in there you know
there's family everybody you but some
people build their house out of other
people and they'll just sleep I can
between them I remember being an Indian
one time and they had people at night
sleeping on the side of the interstate
like on the wall like the interstate
like imagine you're on you know i ten or
i twelve or 55 and there's
just people to sleeping right on the
side of it just blew my mind that's
crazy to Bob I mean just so much smog to
him what else we got
CA 37th horse died at Santa Anita Park
right here in California after
sustaining a leg injury and during the
last day of the Breeders Cup it was a
four-year-old thoroughbred named
Mongolian groom and it suffered a
serious fact fracture and was later
euthanized but yeah it's becoming quite
the epidemic at Santa Anita racetrack
yeah yeah it's really it's almost kind
of become like a real Chop Shop for for
horses and horse eree and that sort of
thing what the deal is I wonder if
there's just like a little bump out the
gate or something but I wonder if
somebody over there is doping oh if they
got some kind of horse Dexter kind of
milling around over there I think that's
pretty likely because you'd have to
think once 30 you know 32 horses died
anybody's ballgame yeah
37 horses the hybra we got a problem and
that's just in one year no no that's
like ever at the track but it I mean the
last one was just like less than a week
ago and yeah it just keeps happening I
it's I feel like there's gonna be a big
backlash against horse racing pretty
soon like there already was against
SeaWorld like I feel like there's gonna
be like a documentary about horse racing
like blackfish pretty soon because well
blackfish is racial - I guess it's like
yeah they had one blackfish and this how
they treated have you seen that I never
heartbreaking but I didn't I don't think
I watched all of it but I watched enough
to get the point Jesus yeah well it
almost makes you want to not want to go
there and really bet on them if you're
like all these guys are dying they're
not treating them well they're not
giving them vitamins and it also makes
you wonder if there's a bigger
conspiracy where it's like oh let's send
some sick horses out here to start to
get the think get the vibe out there
that we don't want to do this anymore
that could be it but you go to other
places brother they got you know they
got a they are they're just getting
horse racing you know you go to some
countries it's like
they're just getting like they'll
they'll race anything out there sheep
you know lamb they got a thing I think
in Louisiana too were sometimes at the
rodeo they'll tie like a kid to a lamb
or something and run him out there it's
beautiful you know the kid they got like
a 18 month old and then they said like a
lamb just at the speed of lightning what
else we got here it says McDonald's yeah
the McDonald's CEO Steve Easterbrook was
forced to leave the company over what
was called a consensual relationship
with an employee they have yet to name
the employee but yeah he had to step
step down he said this was a mistake
given the values of the company I agree
with the board that it's time for me to
move on the values of the company dude
if you can't [ __ ] somebody at a
fast-food shop who can you [ __ ] anymore
that's what I like I don't like this big
you know I don't like you know people
make them feel bad for sex this man
works at a McDonald's you know first of
all you know how hard it is to work in a
McDonald's get off work and still want
to [ __ ] someone very hard I mean can you
imagine even the diet that they're on
probably doesn't even lead to healthy
sexual organ
you know upkeep this is just baffling
man and it's just so it's like most
people met at work most of our parents
met each other at work or they met you
have to meet somebody somewhere you
can't even [ __ ] somebody because both
y'all
you know filled out resumes at the same
building sometimes it's just I mean does
this say that he was like abusing the
person or anything no it sounded like I
said consensual I don't know what the
deal was given the values of the company
there that they have [ __ ] grimace bro
they have purple they have the clown
Ronald McDonald's a clown he's in a
clown to sell [ __ ] fat to children I
don't think I have a lot of companies
over there somebody's [ __ ] in the
back row that's honestly the least of my
concerns
I'm Way more concerned about the people
fist fighting in front of the register
that shows up on Twitter every cup
man if you can't [ __ ] doing that's what
I'm saying dude go to wendy's bruh go to
the one over there off Lincoln Boulevard
the doors are missing on it they'll let
you [ __ ] around now bet that's it Nick
yeah that's it slow news week yeah
pretty slow news week man dead horses
you can't [ __ ] McDonald's dude
sometimes you know I'll go through the
drive-thru it to McDonald's and and you
almost want to offer to [ __ ] the person
who's working in there just to be like
hey you know you're not just working at
McDonald's you're cool you're good treat
him like a person yes that is just
someone's serving your food yeah yeah
because everybody especially if you're
like a youngster you roll in the first
thing you do is like [ __ ] with them over
the loudspeaker which is almost crazy to
have a lot of speaker the ladies like 11
feet around the corner you have to have
this whole system and they kind of like
a little bit of way light gardening over
there it's oh it's just so shady and you
pick out what you want it's so lonely
dude I go there at night sometimes on my
way home god it makes me sad man just
pulling up in the lady knows me and
she's a [ __ ] Patriots fan oh you back
that's what she says every time oh you
bet
undefeated that's what she'll say all
kind of [ __ ] like that and I'm just sad
I'm like don't you think if I [ __ ]
was had a good life I would even be here
I don't care about football right now
you know it's 140 in the morning I'm
getting two cheeseburgers and a sundae
and I know the machines broke but I'm a
[ __ ] order it again
the machines always [ __ ] broke - oh
man anyway let you get to some calls
yeah man I think let me get let me get
into some of these calls we got some
good ones yeah they're pretty pretty
good lots of problems
lots of trouble man need some home are
there yeah alright always will get into
a man if I need your expertise then I'll
holler back at your neck happy and
that's producer Nick Davis they're
always um always helping us out man you
got worked so hard and I'm grateful to
have him uh have him put up with me
alright let's get to some calls here as
always the hotline nine eight five six
six four nine five zero three IPO what's
up Scott from over there in Baton Rouge
the red stick and I'll say this about
Baton Rouge never in my life when I was
in college had I seen more people get
snuck at a bar than in Baton Rouge
Louisiana I mean somebody would just be
standing there and somebody would come
up and just hit him for no damn reason
bruh and that's Baton Rouge bro go
Tigers dude also the amount of fans who
didn't go to college but go to the games
blew my mind
there you'd have people in the stands
they didn't know any other colors except
for purple and gold and that's just SEC
football
yeah people can't read you have some
dude he'd been in a he'll be in a bubble
you know he have a disease and he'll be
in a bubble he have an air disease but
when it's game time brah he'll [ __ ]
unzip that big bag and [ __ ] come out
that [ __ ] he'll be out lurking just
taking his chances I might die but I'm
I'm a witness a couple of these first
downs move the chains alright let's take
the rest of this call thank you for
calling Scott I want to tell you about
the bad weekend I sent my daughter to
the Natchez Mississippi hot-air balloon
festival oh yeah and Natchez Mississippi
out there on the levee they got one of
the most beautiful balloon festivals up
there and that's just an hour's you know
that's just a you know just a stoners
throw from from Baton Rouge homeward and
the dish is done for warm
it was an immaculate time perfect
weather
great atmosphere this gun was awesome
Travis and Vern both came down and gave
us love a daughter she's seven
she was starstruck and help me too
I'd like to thank mrs. gun I'm a single
bed it was really cool to share that
experience with my daughter hope to be
in Lafayette soon and we loves buddy
gang gang brah gang man Thank You
brothers nice you to say that yeah man
it's fun you know I can't imagine what
that's like getting to take your
daughter and do something nice like that
and something fun but good for you for
taking that action and doing it you know
you're not gonna let her have spaces in
her brain where you guys don't where
there should be memories where there
should be things that are meaningful you
know you're gonna feel you're filling
her brain with with important cult you
know and that's important man that's
beautiful do to see that and and I'm
glad they could do it and I think they
have enough their music some of its
goofy and like fun enough we're not
goofy but it's the beats are kind of fun
enough where if a kid is really vibing
into it I think they could you know they
could have fun for a little while so I'm
glad you guys got to do it you know they
are those boys are actually playing in
Tipitina's in New Orleans tonight and I
wish I was gonna be there but but I'll
see you over there in Lafayette man and
uh and and happy early Holidays to you
and yours all right let's take this call
that came in homework hey man my name is
fave you know I got two kids now one was
12 when I was eight okay bro so you took
four years off that off that crotch huh
you backed off that self that hitter off
that little law that wallet bro but you
backed off mom's a little sweat wallet
for about four years for you made that
second batch huh gang
and twelve-year-old say about eight
months ago you know she came out of the
closet to me and her mother the problem
is you know my mother caught wind of it
you know my daughter coming out and all
and she said what were some very hurtful
things about my kid and then you know my
wife got into an argument with her and
she said some very hurtful things about
my wife and now not only have I not
talked to my mother in about five months
I've also not talked to my stepfather or
you know my three brothers in that same
time because you know when these things
happen everybody seems like everybody
takes a side and you know everybody took
mom dukes aside I want to know if you
have any insight or if any of your other
listeners my fellow listeners had any
insight into uh you know into how I
could go about starting to try to repair
these relationships pretty much it
though hopefully after you out there we
on the road gang brah thanks for the
call that's a good question you know if
you have a say your child and 12 you
know and I'm not judging I'm just
showing from my own experience 12 seemed
a little young for a child to know
full-throttle
what kind of nookie they like or what
kind of attraction they have but but
maybe it's not now maybe children are so
ramped up or just advanced that they
know what's up I mean I remember I saw a
couple middle schoolers making out one
time when I was driving two young boys
kind of tender kind of gentleman kind of
boys and dude I pulled over I said hey
guys you know maybe give it give it two
years and see what's up you know does
these boys were 11 and they were kissing
out there and it's fine but it's just
like sometimes it gets they get you know
children can just get easily influenced
you know you see people doing drug you
do drug you see people you know kissing
um somebody you kiss somebody you know
you see somebody start a fire you start
a fire so
but um but look it sounds like you that
you have no doubt about uh about you
know what your daughter where her sexual
laurels lie and that's tough man you
know what's tough really is balancing
like because like our parents and
grandparents especially you get some of
their generations things were just
different and I'm not saying that things
in their generation were right but for
the time they were in they behaved in a
way that was fitting or more accepted or
sometimes they probably were maybe even
afraid like I bet there was a time you
know sixty years ago people might have
been afraid to say hey I support someone
who's gay that might have might have
been a fear whereas now it's almost like
a fear to say if you were to say I don't
support gay people you know people would
be more fearful of that so it's
interesting cuz it's like we don't give
people a pass I don't feel like as much
as we should on their on their
perspective based on their world
you know if somebody grew up in the dark
and you trying to tell them about light
bulbs and [ __ ] they ain't ya gonna tell
you to go smoke a [ __ ] you know to smoke
half a bowl of your own dead and that's
facts Jack because they don't know it
and if they come to a party where
everybody got the lights on and they
shut them all the lights off to them
that's gonna be normal you know eating
cake in the dark is normal to them
because that's what they know but now if
your mother got if she got now with the
part that where you it's a little you
know where it's is when your mother if
she was saying mean stuff that's the
thing that's too much really it's just
not you know no one should do that to a
child especially and
and you have to take your child side
yeah I mean obviously there's no that's
the right move it sounds like that you
you know you're doing that you know I
don't have that experience because you
know I've never been a gay man and I've
never had a twelve-year-old child tell
me they were gay if a kid told me he was
gay man I would tell them you know well
you know it looks fun a lot of gay
people have a lot of fun so
but don't dress up like damn little
mermaid bra if unless you trust your
friends
not to leave you that dude was just a
little roadside crowd out there your boy
but yeah I think it's a great question
maybe some of our listeners have a
similar experience yeah must be it's
just interesting how from like you know
times and generations like things you
can't even say anymore even if you're
just joking too you know things that
were just read you know like our
grandparents could you know our
grandparents like everything's just a
lot more transparent now and I think
back then our grandparent they just
weren't used to the transparency they
weren't used to they just weren't used
to the transparency of it and people
like to make their world they don't want
to people don't like to change a lot of
times we want to make you know okay this
is the way the world is and I lived in
it and and that's the way it'll always
be
you know we don't want to admit that the
world changes are the people's views
change or that that society like change
I mean dude in two hundred years
everybody could be bisexual who knows it
could be the way that science takes us
and then we nobody exists anymore
because nobody has a wiener or a vagina
everybody has a vagina and nothing you
can't make a baby everybody's just
beaten their crotches against each other
but no babies you know that could be the
day new mom at all how it all shapes out
we don't know so
at that point people would be like damn
we got to get some couple straight
people up here to the front lines to
[ __ ] to do it right to do some nookie to
nuki out you know to throw you know to
throw that body water into each other so
they can have a child so you know a lot
of hearsay out there but if a child if
you believe the kid and they know for a
fact I guess it's well view know what
age is that fifth grade
yeah maybe these days that's how it is I
think usually you have to wait to
somebody's probably seventh grade for
they know if they're definitely going to
be gay but kids go through phases
sometimes you might go through it you
know especially these days I don't think
it's it's not wild if somebody's gay for
a year or 18 months and I'm not saying
that it's like they can't be gay forever
if they do whatever they want but
sometimes people be like oh I'm gonna be
gay for July that's a thing you'll see
out here sometimes you know it's really
some guy who's really gay forever and
he's trying to sneak you you know trying
to get you to come over and enlist you
know so but yeah that's great if people
have some suggestions how to mend those
fences because yeah you don't want
people fighting forever over this I
can't believe your mom was yeah who's
yelling at a 12 year old kid about about
that unless your parents just didn't
believe them you know because a lot of
kids these days they say they're all you
know you'll have kids saying I'm you
know this is you know all kinds of like
political stances and all kinds of stuff
and and you're like dude you know you
ain't [ __ ] you know you don't have a
you're not doing you don't even have a
job so but yeah it's interesting as like
because a lot of like perspectives and
people's you know old views and new
views they're having a tough time
but I don't think you should shun all
old people because they believe
something different or they were brought
up in a different time because sometimes
if they do believe what was what people
believe now or what's more common now
more practices they would have been they
could have been ostracized at that time
so it's not it's just this weird
teeter-totter sometimes but
congratulations to your daughter for
figuring that out
I'm sure it's interesting to navigate
and be supportive you know and learn how
to I'm sure it's a really time where you
learn how to be real loving when
somebody comes at you I mean look the
first set of tits I saw on somebody was
on a man that were 3d I saw drawn as I'd
seen some drawing tits and I'd seen my
mother's tits and I'm sorry Maya I think
she listens to this but I'd seen some
drawing tits and then they had this boy
and he was a beautiful ginger guy and he
uh and he was real thick you know he was
that real just that [ __ ] that doughy
Joey he was real like a you know like a
big pastry or pass tree and he uh and he
had tits on him and sometimes I would
look at him and and just kind of cover
my hands I've talked about this before
and I would just make a shape with my
hand in front of my eye where all I
could see was his breasts and pretending
was a woman I feel my body get really
you know that feel that little baby
diving-board start up in between my legs
feel that baby shark start growing and
suddenly I feel like a damn shark
because my I got that weiner fin bra so
praise God man what else we got here
what else we got here here we got a call
that came in ninety five six six four
nine five zero three what's that do this
is fart
I'm from Macon Georgia Martin from Macon
and I bet everything people always say
make
and bacon and stuff like that and uh
since it because everything that that
because one thing is popular that rounds
with making his bacon so I'm sure y'all
got to hear all that [ __ ] old Tom
quaking forsaken you know a lot of
churches probably right little cute
things on the sign you know you know
don't be forsaken and making breaking oh
we've had a lot of break-ins and makin
so awkward and last Friday I got two
weeks in at work I'm calling because
I've got two dogs not showing Taco not
so I bought Omo and taco was bought for
me by the hunting lodge that I don't
work out and you know that's going to be
a point of contention now because I'm
believing at the beginning of the season
and the owner of the lodge just trying
to [ __ ] me out of this dog man he's
trying to take taco from me after I've
taken care of dogs for the last six
months of radius didn't trained it and
he's pretty hard time his rough around
there just like sick people over and you
know I'm trying to get out of here
without burning any bridges but if you
trust to take this dog probably that I
don't know what's going to happen it
sees me uh because not serving taco more
obvious if brothers at this point I want
to do everything I'm not proud to keep
them together when I leave here anyhow
it would be would be much appreciated
less love
gang bro look nacho and taco might be
brothers they might not I can't I'm not
sure just because you put something next
to each other for a long time doesn't
make it a brother you know what I'm
saying if you put you take a hitchhiker
and you take a UH somebody who works at
the mall you stand them next to each
other for six years they still might not
get they still there's nothing between
them you know they might there's nothing
as soon as you say go one of them's
going back to work on one of them's
[ __ ] you know filming it to st. Louis
so you can't
you can't just make animals be brothers
only God can do that so what I'm saying
is you have to figure out it sounds like
if a communication issue bruh I mean
this guy knows what he's expecting you
have what you're expecting you trained
him it sounds like the dog was it given
to you was it loaned to you it sounds a
gift some communication but if [ __ ] hits
the fan bruh throw that [ __ ] in the
back seat fire off a couple rounds bro
you know I would do warning shots only
man that's the big thing people forget
about warning shots a lot of times
people just already shoot somebody you
know what also works boom boom
warning shots think about it if somebody
sees you shoot a gun twice in the air
the next logical thought to them is
honor gonna shoot me so I do warning
shots brought fire 5060 warning shots
and after that you can usually it's
usually really clear communication with
people after that so you know I mean
it's getting Wild West out there if you
got to shoot something up a little bit
to get that animal then you know people
love animals and I can start to see it a
little bit more I've been attacked by a
lot of different animals and you know
I've been having dreams recently or semi
recently that um that there was a parrot
in Bethlehem in the manger in that baby
shed I've had a lot of different dreams
about that because if you notice in a
lot of the drawings in a lot of those
freaking md's brothers manger drawings
they are the
the animals are real sedentary animals
you got a mule in there you got a lamb
or sheep
you got a donkey you got a cow some of
you have a cow in there which is kind of
weird a cow how you get a cow all the
way out there in the desert like that is
unbelievable we have a camel with a
little hat on
but a lot of people you wouldn't think
they'd have a parrot in there but I have
a lot of Dreams where you see there is a
parrot and he's just kind of you know
just no crib for a bed you know where's
the North Star you know I have a lot of
dreams about things that we didn't you
know behind the scenes of the manger
because here's the thing three old dudes
go out to the desert to visit a kid
brought that's a Dateline episode today
so I'm not saying it didn't happen I
believe full forthright I believe 700
percent that it happened but but if that
can happen dude there could be a couple
rare animals in there you could have a
raccoon out there hanging out behind the
little the little baby crib they had
something in there they had a couple
raccoons they had a couple of um you
know aardvarks or something up in that
[ __ ] I mean that's Bethlehem though so
but yeah do what you got to do out there
pop a stay woke bra and if that she
here's the thing you have to answer
directly to yourself is that your dog or
is that not your dog I know if
something's my dog if I go up to a dog
and it ain't my dog brah it ain't my dog
just coming sleeping with somebody's
wife for six months don't make it my
wife
that's his wife even if I'm teaching her
new tricks and I'm too you know and I
bought her one of those um you know
omelet makers that folds over it's like
the pan that has the little hinges in
the middle in it it doesn't matter
none of that [ __ ] matters man what
matters is the facts what matters is the
documentation who saw the bay you know
was it given to you was it not you know
the answer so then you need to build up
to start to part ways with the animal if
you want to not burn bridges or you need
to [ __ ] get a stack of matches dog
and like the [ __ ] Golden Gate up son
burn that [ __ ] sorry ma'am but it's
it's November bro it's no vote it's no
burn ver something to burn [ __ ] man if
you have to not everything can not burn
so every now and then something's got a
torch out gang [ __ ] alright let's take a
call here nine eight five six six four
nine five zero three thank you a hair
from Paso Robles California hey Pamela
from Paso Robles and you think Paso
Robles that sounds like somebody about
to get naked in Mexico you know I'm
saying when you hear somebody say oh
Paso Robles say damn well let me put the
ladder a little closer to window cuz I'm
about to watch them
deep bass come out okay you had a
wonderful Halloween by myself Esther
four large bags of candies a bunch of
kilos kids to come to my house and and
then my husband was picked up by
Homeland Security was trying to smuggle
in 17 kilos worth of methamphetamine
into the state Wow now that donkey was
not in Bethlehem mental thing and that's
the thing about Bethlehem then I'll show
you the x-rays the MRIs of the animals
some of them have dope in their body in
their colon Oh word
I'm sitting here at work trying not to
think about it and having a rough time
James and I thought I would call and get
that off my chest I may or may not be
the last time I see her I think because
this is not her first this is her first
homeland security strike but it was
definitely not her first strike she's
been stuck around with that that
addiction for 12 15 years and all of
them almost all of my life in 2009 was
30 miles throw on the fall in my life
thank you so much for having this
hotline to that - mmm yeah yeah okay
okay love it love you too miss oh I
didn't know I thought she was mewling it
I thought she was just for vending I
didn't know that she had an addiction
problem man it's crazy
that's heavy you know cuz having a
vagina that's definitely Jesus you know
if I had a wiener that had like a little
grocery bag hooked to it I'd probably be
running drugs all the time doing this or
doing that
stealing squashes are stealing a couple
um what are those things where you put
the butter on them and people like I'm
kind of but they don't really like them
asparagus no I'm talking about um
and you artichokes so in a vagina that's
one of the problems if you have drugs or
something of the John it becomes
basically just a place to hide something
in your body and so when you have
addiction you don't think of it you know
you don't even think of this as a
feminine area anymore you think of it as
just a tool chest you know you think of
it as just a little like a chest of
drawers oh I'll put this dope right here
in this crazy you know pouch in between
my legs and this extra you know this
kind of just like you know a little
glory bucket or just like a satchel so
man it's unfortunate you know maybe this
here's a thing
maybe the
to be the thing that shakes her back in
a reality because everybody you got to
hit your bottom before you start to get
a foundation and everybody's bottom is a
different place some people's bottom is
way up here it's not a low-bottom some
people like that low bottom they just
real sonic the hedghog when it comes to
the drugs or the you know pornography or
whatever and it's as fight and it's a
struggle and I hope that she gets it I
hope that this is a blessing in the
skies and this is that thing this is the
merry-go-round that turns her back to
you know to reality and a year from now
you see her come around the edge and
they got a mirror buyer and like a fake
horse and a damn you know cinnamon stick
and she's on a damn you know she's
coming around the bend and uh because
yet there's not I mean it's it's funny
because the things we do when we're in
addiction some of them are just cries
for help and maybe that's what this is
in a weird way but I wish her well and I
think it's sweet that you care about her
so much and I mean who knows that
Christmastime she could be sixty days
sober and and really have a whole new
perspective and hopefully this will be
that for her alright what else man we
got it we got to pay the bills here and
you guys if you want to support the
podcast and support it could we'll take
it you know I want to let you know that
if you are struggling with something and
I struggle look I'm struggling right now
a pornography man I've had you know I
was doing well and then this past really
this past six months man I've really had
a tough time with not pornography as
much but cigarettes and just man but I'm
tired I'm tired of swimming in the same
circle I'm tired of it man I'm tired of
when them pet when they when the rat
hits the road of you know not having
enough cheese in the fridge to [ __ ]
say okay I'm gonna it's gonna be
different this time
so yeah and it's just you know it's a
battle we stay fighting though you know
we stay fighting and that's what we do
here and I hope that your cousin does
the same this episode is brought to you
by better help better help we'll assess
your needs and match you with your own
licensed professional therapist you know
I've used better help and it's a way you
can start communicating with a therapist
in less than 24 hours because here's one
thing that I don't like about therapy
you got to find one you got to go
through the thing and you got to call
the insurance and it takes a day and
they got to email you back the list and
next thing you know you've got to make
sure they end schedule or in utero or in
whatever in program next you know you
find out they only got one dude who you
can see you got to drive 70 miles he's
on a mountaintop and the dudes hiding
mushrooms in his butt and you're like
damn bro he don't he's just a seance er
he get up there you get up there and he
and even he just works at the post
office you're like Jesus but that's why
I better help is here for you you can
start communicating in less than 24
hours with a licensed professional
counselor it's not a crisis line it's
not self help it is professional
counseling done securely online there's
a broad range of expertise and better
helps counselor network which may not be
locally available in many areas so you
might be able to talk to someone if you
suffering from sex addiction or sex and
love addiction you know it's funny
because I would notice for myself that a
lot of times if I would go out with
drugs or do something like that or it
was always surrounding a woman there was
always a female or some tits involved in
it nearby if you catch me near some coke
and you look in the distance there might
be tits around because one of them
always had to do with the other I was
really there was some feelings there was
some validation I needed from women or
something or
whatever that ended up steering me
towards drugs or even just experiment
just messing around with drugs I wasn't
real wild about it but it was enough of
the times where I noticed like oh I was
rejected or this made me feel this way
and then next thing you know I'm you
know I'm spackling the inside of my
[ __ ] face with that canary powder bra
you feel me with that [ __ ] that
parrot flower that cocaine so you get
timely and thoughtful responses on
better help you can schedule weekly
video or phone sessions you won't ever
have to sit in an uncomfortable waiting
room as with traditional there but you
got to sit out there looking through a
you know y-you know uh twelve year old
wives magazine and you're like what is
this about and just a different it's
just something else they don't you don't
know so you want to sit out there some
guy keeps blowing his nose into his
sleeve and something and he feeds it to
a little mouse that he have in his
pocket you don't have to deal with this
[ __ ] better help is committed to
facilitating great therapeutic matches
so they'll make it easy and free to
change counselors if needed free to
change counselors better he'll want you
to start living a happier life today
visit better help calm slash th e oh
that's B e TT ER h ELP and join the over
500,000 people it's taking charge of
their mental health with the help of an
experienced professional that's right
this past weekend listeners get 10% off
your first month at better help calm
slash Theo and I'll say this we're going
to get into some more calls we got some
good ones have come in and thank you
guys for sharing you know being willing
to share what's going on with you with
me and just thinking about stuff you
know yeah I've been struggling a lot a
lot with the cigarettes recently and I'm
just tired of just going in these
circles minyan at a certain point I just
gotta [ __ ] be strong enough to just
get just but then it's like man I don't
want to not have anything you know
you know can't drink can't do drugs
can't it's just hard man it's hard
sometimes you know and I know there's
our stuff out there to make me feel good
I know those things but sometimes it's
still like you know you just want to you
just you know I don't like not being
able to do what I want to do I don't
like something or someone telling me
what I can and can't do but that's just
small picture me and big picture me
knows that that there's better ways to
there's better methods and there's
better things I can do that will
actually bring me some long-term joy
then it's getting that short-term
[ __ ] that little puffy puffy dude a
little dirty sick idealism wrong then
readies bro going last I had I got to
tell you zip recruiter I'll say this
cafe all tourists Dylan Mishka wits
needed to hire a director of coffee for
his organic coffee company but he was
having trouble finding qualified
applicants that makes sense if you go
outside and yell outside hey I need help
with this coffee director you could get
anybody you could get somebody selling
drugs you could get any money so he
switched to zip recruiter zip recruiter
doesn't depend on candidates finding you
it finds them for you it's technology
identifies people with the right
experience and invites them to apply to
your job so you get qualified candidates
fast that's the thing I'm a zip
recruiter it's gonna hey it's gay it's
saying hey who cares enough to make a
good resume who cares enough to look for
a job who cares enough to to take action
in their life those are the people I
want to apply for my job and that's what
zip recruiter does it there it already
has those people it serves them right to
you
and that's how Ilyn find his new
director of coffee in just a few days
it's no wonder four out of five
employers who post on zip recruiter get
a quality candidate within the first day
and as for all types of jobs could be a
yard worker could be a tree climber it
could be somebody that looks for
something treasure man see why zip
recruiters effective for businesses of
all sizes try it for free at the web
address zip recruiter dot-com slash tpw
that's zi p re crui ter dot-com /t p w
zip recruiter comm slash t pw zip
recruiter the smartest way to hire and I
wish I had a cousin had a couple kilos
on him when I used to go hard damn bro
God sometime you just want that cocaine
snake to just climb up into your body
dude and start looking for [ __ ]
Rubik's cubes you feel me man
sometimes you just want a big cocaine
snake to just climb right up in here as
a boy alright let's take a call here
onward hey he calling from Texas but
anyways I'm calling today I don't know I
have this as an issue it was my brother
I mean I feel like I kind of hate him
feel like he doesn't give a [ __ ] about
me growing up as a kid like we were yeah
we live with my mom serious divorce like
whenever my dad I would say he was gonna
come pick me up I was like always look
out the window my dad would never show
up and said every time I heard the car
drive by I would always run in the
window and look out beautiful tender it
was and I remember one brother always
telling me like I called me stupid
saying he doesn't love us he doesn't
care about us like what am i doing and
then when I'm 19 I find out like my dad
dies I find out that my brother had a
relationship with them at some point
like they were hanging out it was doing
[ __ ] together and I didn't find out
until after my dad died and I found out
because my dad died and that really
needs to feel a lot of resentment
towards my brother because it's like
what the [ __ ]
oh why are you keeping me from him and
for me maybe it wasn't his choice I
don't know I have a lot of issues with
him I don't know how to tell him that
really talk to him about it but uh
hopefully maybe construct my I don't
know man game bro thanks for calling man
I really appreciate it
that's a nice seat us to uh to call and
I'm sorry to hear about the situation
you know a lot of it I can relate to
because my brother and I had a similar
relationship you know we didn't get
along really when we rich kid we were
kids we did actually there was no
connectivity you know my brother and I
were brothers by blood but there was no
real you know our family we didn't love
each other there was no you know no one
ever taught us like oh we're a family
and we stick together there was none of
that kind of [ __ ] I just I just felt
like I just been sentenced to live in a
house with a couple other people and it
was because there was no connection you
know I think one of the ways somehow
that you can I don't think you can hold
your brother
you can't hold it him against him that
he didn't share your dad with you once
he met him once they hung out or
whatever your dad was the one problem
you know who's chose not to be around
unless your mother didn't allow him to
be around that happens sometimes
sometimes the mothers they don't allow
it but if that's not the case then if
your dad didn't if he wasn't there man
he wasn't there so once your brother
kind of got to spend time like that
little bit of time or whatever you know
I think you're really mad at your dad
and I think that there's probably like a
grieving you know I think there's there
might be a grieving program or 12-step
program that you could use for grieving
that you could join for loss you know
that people have lost someone and they
might be able to help you in there you
might be able to have a gather something
from them that's what I think even if
you just went in there and listened to
their story
even if you didn't think you could
relate I bet some of the feelings they
have surrounding loss and uh and missed
opportunities but that was your data
your dad's opportunity that you missed
that he missed you know he missed the
chance to get to know you you know and
so often we like you know we just it's
so fun it's so amazing how like how much
of a young man is all we want is just to
see our dad to see us it's almost like
it's just your only real purpose is to
make you as - as for our father to see
us to recognize us
you know our fathers they're just a boy
you know sadly they're just a boy
they're just you know they become a man
but sometimes they don't so now somebody
didn't teach them well you know and
sometimes it's it's interesting because
it goes down generation to generation
and you know you have to beat your anger
that you have to find some way all right
I don't know if you have to but you
don't have to do anything but the way
that humanity wins is if we're able to
cut off the problem you know if we're
able to change our heart or change our
ways so that we say I'm not going to do
the same thing that happened to me
because the easy thing and the way that
you have an easy way out is if you have
a kid one day you don't really you're
not there for the kid you always have
somebody to blame you can blame your dad
you always have somebody to blame a lot
can this blame him and that's the easy
way out and nobody could breathe people
can point fingers at you but really they
point in maturing and they point them
upwards over to Daddy
but the the the mastery I think in life
comes if we're able to stop the stop
that that that inherited just dying
[ __ ] bruh I mean its sheer dying
[ __ ] bruh SDF and just to be able to
stop it and to be able to find you find
some way you know whether it's through a
program or through talking with others
or whatever it is do where you're able
to find a way to forgive him and find
empowerment inside of yourself so when
you're a dad one day or that you won't
let the same thing happen you don't let
it happen with you and your kid your kid
never knows any of those feelings what
that's like you know and that's how we
win that's how we win and it sucks man
so it sucks sometimes because the way
you know but if that's not how you get
here like if you don't that's how you
got here you don't exist otherwise the
only way you exist just about is with
that mom and that dad that's the only
way you exist and and that's a blessing
you're here this is it this is the rod
bruh and it's bareback man you know and
I think just do your best to love your
brother you know he probably you don't
know what it was like for him you know
if he doesn't communicate it that well
or doesn't communicate it the way you
want it to be communicated with him then
that's that's just he's gonna be what
he's gonna be and you can't hold it
against and we just got to find some way
to just find some joy and to stop that
thing from happening you got it we do
week you know that's when we win when we
stop for this we're not gonna Jeanette
we're not gonna pass this thing down
again we're gonna stop we're gonna
change our behavior and so this doesn't
happen to me
because the blessing is you could have
been your fault what if you you know you
know the higher powers had moved you
guys up a generation and you could be
what if you were your dad and you had a
son and you don't see him but that's not
what they did they said hey we're gonna
make you the son we're gonna make you
the pivotal piece that can change it
that can change the behavior and change
the course because you gonna need to
shovel the rivers running like this you
will need a shovel and you have to do
some work to uh to bend that waterway
and create a different you know a
different traversing of water you got to
got a dick we got to get a new canal
going and that's really a blessing man
that the higher powers of the universe
put it on you they said we this is the
boy that can do it he's the one that can
go through this part where he gets left
out by his father and he's the one who
can turn this river you know he's the
one who can do it because it could have
been you could have been up a generation
and you you you just be the daddy and
you have a son and you know you're out
bowling or something or doing [ __ ]
frisbee golf or something and doing coke
and you never see your son but that's
not what they did your dad took that L
and if you think it was probably
enjoyable for your father
I bet it wasn't man
I couldn't imagine anything more painful
than not seeing my kid even if I would
pretend there wasn't even if I if I
would pretend it wasn't painful
I couldn't imagine anything that in my
real heart of heart would hurt me more a
bit and I don't even have a damn kid bro
so but who knows man they got children
out there you know two six-year-olds
just came out of the closet bro so it's
it's getting you know it's things are
changing is getting unique out there do
that I wish my nuts were square man
don't you
you ever wish your nuts our score square
I was stacking bro you here I'm stacked
them bad cats oh that nut stacker you
know who he is everybody wouldn't know
all right let's take this call right
here
hey hey Evan thank you for calling man
and Minnesota beautiful place out there
they saw they have the that's where the
Mississippi River begins up there in
Lake Itasca and you can pee in it right
there at the top and I mean it's only
about half a foot wide so it's real easy
to just kind of pee right into homework
okay you down there near Iowa then you
close some people don't know a lot of
people you know don't know how land is
and so they don't know that Minnesota
and Iowa share a border home word kinda
made a full circle move myself I've been
livin up in the cities living down in
Mankato kind of do my thing for a while
and you know you kind of get to that age
where family just kind of take a
different perspective and you know my
dad kind of had an accident was in high
school he's got some back issues you
know and to hear him struggling you know
working his butt off all the time you
know I'm the older brother of two you
know so kind of [ __ ] I needed to step up
everything so I'm back home we're
farming harvest time getting those
soybeans in that that sweet corn out of
the ground so just I've been feeling a
good man dude that's awesome man
beautiful to get back and help your dad
you over there and that's family romance
right there when you care about somebody
and you go help them that's family
romance bro when you win that love for
your family cuz we go through these
stages I find anyway I go through these
stages where it's like you don't look
you know you're just thinking about
yourself and it's your own life and
you're sprouting like a bean but then
you start to get big and you realize oh
man you know really I'll miss my roots
you know I love being a plant but man I
just I really miss my roots
oh let's hear more didn't think I'd ever
end up back home in my hometown where I
came from but you know working with my
family and being around my brother it's
just been amelie an experience I'm just
still into abandoned but I love our gang
gang getting them hitters up on that
corn a 8 a.m. to 1 a.m. baby let's go
get it
gang brah and you got a love corn if you
don't love corn then something's wrong
with you think about yourself
do you love corn if you said no
something's wrong with y'all something's
wrong with cha because you you think
about all the kind of corn to have corn
sweet corn candy corn regular corn
popcorn corn on the cob corn bread
Cornish game hen corn unicorn I mean
that's if you if having if having 9
types of corn ain't enough for you then
and if you said no to all 9 types then
yeah something's wrong with you you
probably shouldn't be alive that's all
I'm saying
and I'm not threatening you this ain't
nothing like that I'm just saying if one
out of nine types of corn you can't
exacerbate to one of them then you are
the problem
you think corns the problem 9 times corn
comes at you 9 different ways and you
can every time you can't you know find a
comfortable landing space inside of your
heart for that ce o-- r n boy then
you're the problem there should be a
corn test you but you just you do one
after the other in front of some person
if they say no to all nine bro
sayonara boy
welcome to sword practice boy you going
to heaven so but you know it's never too
late bruh
you know this young man didn't think he
was gonna be out there and now he's back
at home and it's just man it's like no
matter what we're doing it's like if we
if if it's going to be joyous we got to
make it joyous joy don't just happen you
know we got to bring it you know change
this doesn't happen we say it all the
time but yeah nothing changes if nothing
changes tomorrow you're not going to
wake up and your relationships going to
be different it's not going to happen
unless you do something to affect it and
I'm not telling you what to do I don't
know what I'm talking about but I'm
telling you that I've spent time you
know and love somebody but I didn't care
enough to do a lot of the work that it
takes to make it mean something and when
the game went and and when that when and
when it ends if it ends you don't you
want to look back at the game and just
you want to have played it you know you
want to have have played it
and yeah it's never too late you know
it's never too late to get I was talking
about this last week and I don't know
why I'm saying and I'm not taught I'm
just talking because I need to hear
myself say these things you know it's
never too late to uh to not give up on
yourself you know when to get out of
your brain and get into action and make
some changes it can be small but to tell
somebody you love them to to spend some
time with that kiddo to take them to
that Bishop gun show and see a balloon
race instead of just relaxing for the
afternoon you know to surprise your wife
at lunch or you love when or something
or even if your wife if you if you are
oh if you want to if you are someone you
know if you more have more of a
homoerotic kind of tendency surprise
your same-sex loved one with a sandwich
or Widow um you know one of them four
inch rounds I think is back at Subway
get them something you know there's
nothing more beautiful than two people
out there eating a four inch round or
something there's just you know it's a
limited time in but it's never too late
to get over it's never too late to
adjust that flow and there's no better
time really to uh to surprise people or
to bring somebody back into your life or
to adjust the pattern that's going on
then then the holidays it's the olive
branch of the calendar forgiveness is
built into it do you go you take
somebody to an orange latte or somebody
get somebody a spiced you know one of
them cornucopia hats or something buy
somebody a damn clove there's a million
opportunities to really to blend and you
got this [ __ ]
and we go [ __ ] hard son and we don't
give up on ourselves and we change the
tune we change the tune baby let's go
you know what I'm saying let's go we got
this [ __ ] and they say you can't do it
and you can do it and you say you can't
do it that's the crazy part a lot of
times the Vey is you it's me it's us
it's ourselves you know I sometimes
think how can my worst enemy live in my
head but that's the challenge of life
that's what separates you know people
just must grass from Mountain cats baby
the one that can see what their brain is
trying to do to him and the one that
says starts getting that brain to work
for them and we got this we got this man
good luck to everybody out there have a
good day have a good night
tickle somebody tickle your spouse when
was the last time you tickled them
tickle your [ __ ] cousin brother took
her your fat cousin you know he's gonna
like it but he say you don't like it he
gonna like it you know it's okay man buy
somebody a little thing of tater tots
for lunch bra somebody at work you think
y'all don't get along behind my shake or
something buy my strawberry shake buy
him a snack you see some little fella
you know he you know he dressed up like
a mermaid pickers throw his little ass
up you know put him in an aquarium bruh
repurpose that little bastard you know
it's never too late
and as always this is Stevie starlight
and he's been with us since the
beginning man this music man with his
hit it's never too late to come over
[Music]
[Applause]
to make a dream higher than a mountain
just don't set me free baby just don't
say goodbye
[Music]
to
chip-chop
[Applause]
sound slips away from you
[ __ ] yeah so don't hesitate to come o it
to yourself way
and that's Stevie starlight come over
and you can find that on YouTube and
Stevie was a guest early on the show and
and he's one of a kind and so are you
and so am i and we got this you know
sometimes it's not always the victory so
know me this it's the fight but we don't
give up one more week
we did it we hear you here we're gonna
be ok you guys be good to yourselves you
deserve it huh and thank you for
reminding me to do the same okay